Internet,
Savior or destroyer that neither.
I don't think it's going to make any
significant difference.
Don remitting only interested in the
message.
I am prodigious Lee uninterested in the
medium.
The Internet is just another way of
writing things down.
Citizen Journalism.
And it sounds so wonderful.
It sounds like something from the French
Revolution,
isn't it?
Um,
do you want a citizen dentist?
Our media,
our publications at the moment are a
wash with highly paid columnist who by
and large have nothing to say.
Uh,
no.
Very little.
Yep.
Four of the largest of the top 10 new
sites on the way are aggregators.
Google,
AOL,
Yahoo,
Microsoft.
They don't generate news.
They collect other people's news.
Rupert Murdoch has now declared war on
Google.
It's not Google's fault that everyone
was so stupid.
Ah,
and he is going to progressively put
more and more of his content behind what
we call a pay wall.
And I welcome that.
And I hope a lot of other proprietors,
we'll do the same.
The big get bigger in,
in these kind of perpetual declines and
obviously the smaller quality,
uh,
titles are the ones that have a greater
trouble hanging on.
There's always some financial basis for
this work.
It's not free.
And the reason is it takes an enormous
amount of time to produce very good
content and money.
If you look at the comments at the
bottom of articles on newspaper
websites,
they are awesome.
I mean they are properly knuckle
dragging.
Most of the stuff that comes on chat
rooms and on blogs,
it's beyond corporate and Sinead is
idiocy.
You,
you or relate to the reader in a
fundamentally different way.
When I used to write for magazines,
you would publish your article and maybe
some letters that would come in the mail
a week later,
by which point you'd totally moved on
and forgotten about the subject.
And of course most people didn't bother
to write it all.
Now,
within an hour of anything I publish on
slate.
Uh,
there are hundreds of comments and now
that we've sort of gotten better at
figuring out how to do comments,
it's quite a good conversation that I
participate in and I depend on that.
I don't,
I don't write to speak from on high to
an invisible audience.
I write to relate to an audience of
people,
many of whom I start to know and
recognize because they're so responsive
to what I do.
There's reviews on the Nasher incredibly
successful.
Lots of people follow them.
Most of them are written by theater
producers.
Why wouldn't they be?
You think someone's going to say,
I can't do that because I put money into
the production.
The question about news generation on a
thin news day,
do we make it up?
No,
we don't make it up.
We,
we eke it out.
We can put up and we,
we look at on that,
we spin it out and we generally sort of
stuff it forward a little bit,
but we don't absolutely make it up.